Japan is expected to start development of the F-3 in 2021.
Currently, Japan needs to protect themselves from China.
Japan announced last month, that it will move manufacturing out of China.
Furthermore, Japan expects to have the F-3 fully operational in this decade.
Japanese experts are putting forward advanced technologies in the future jet.
It is highly likely the new jet will include a combat laser,...
...or possibly an electromagnetic weapon.
Thus far, the F-3 sixth generation fighter jet has been dubbed the Mitsubishi F-3.
It can be a contender on the global scale when it comes to fighter jets.
Japan does not plan to stop using F-35, even when the F-3 will be completed.
At present, the appearance of the Mitsubishi F-3 is at the concept stage,...
...but some information has been leaked in Japan.
According to the leaked images,...
...the Japanese fighter will be equipped with two engines, most likely XF9-1,...
...with a fantastic afterburner thrust,...
...which is twice the thrust of the AL-31F engine for the su-27.
The possibility of equipping the aircraft with engines...
...with a 20 degree variable thrust vector is also being considered,...
...which will make the Mitsubishi F-3 super maneuverable.